time now for our seen and unseen segment
where we exposed the big cultural
stories of the day the NFL joins forces
with a music giant and Bernie Sanders
pairs off with cardi B joining us now
with all the details is Raymond Arroyo
Fox News contributor Raymond tell us
about this unbelievable press conference
that took place today announcing a new
partnership between the NFL and Jay Z
Jesse the Kaepernick kneeling protests
during the national anthem enraged NFL
fans while inspiring some of the NFL
players now to channel the player
protests over what they described as
police brutality on this night of all
nights the NFL committed eighty nine
million dollars to something called
inspire change that's their social
justice program well today Roger Goodell
appeared with the man headlining that
effort for the NFL Jay Z this
partnership in addition to the
entertainment aspect and bringing
football music together is going to help
us make even greater change and and we
call it protest to progress right we
need to make progress these communities
just having a place where we can have
these conversations where it's like Oh
things are going on wrong in the country
you know people are dying in these
neighborhoods ok where do we go again
they don't want everyone everyone yeah
there's a natural emotion to be upset
but where do we go now where we going to
take it what are we gonna do how do we
fix it the idea here Jesse is to use
music and social activism to change
society and jay-z during the presser
identified police brutality as the
target of their efforts now this is the
guy who wrapped this incidentally
jaesi turned down the NFL when they
asked him to perform at the Super Bowl
Jesse and and now they're embracing him
because it's a huge platform and no
doubt worth millions and millions of
dollars and like that jay-z said he's
willing to work with people whom he
disagrees with politically now that's
not a bad thing that I'll commend him
for but let's not lose sight of what the
NFL is it's football right I'm quite
certain these fans are not paying these
high prices to protest cops particularly
with what you covered earlier tonight in
Philadelphia I think that's the last
thing on the minds of NFL fans but that
they mean the NFL to embrace jay-z's
vision of social justice now this is a
guy who sold drugs he stabbed his
brother in the face still this
partnership is being billed as a way to
unify America but his memory serves
jay-z had trouble unifying with his
sister-in-law Solange Knowles soon as
the doors closed Beyonce's sister
Solange whips her attention to Bea's
husband jay-z
seemingly shouting at him definitely
punching and kicking him and finally
smacking him with her purse okay this is
my first Raymond Arroyo segment so I'm
at a loss for words here I am too I
would say this Raymond yeah it seems
like big organizations like the NFL or
like Nike is doing with Kaepernick
they're bringing on these social justice
liaisons to help them navigate through
tender issues racial issues things like
that that might give these big
organizations problems and if you bring
a guy in with street cred or with guys
with the zero to the street or that has
you know great credibility in the black
community that could kind of cushion any
sort of negative press that that
organization could face Jesse there's no
doubt look they're trying to buy cred in
the community and that's what the NFL is
up to here but remember jay-z is going
to have creative control over who sings
at the Superbowl know who's a part of
Bell productions this is a major but he
gets to pick the Super Bowl halftime
show yes he does
what yes I don't think this I bet
Beyonce singing next year we'll check in
on Bernie and cardi another time thank
you very much RAM and I appreciate it